the the Pence's are in trouble again
they're in they're in big trouble the
left is shocked yet again to learn that
the Pence's are Christian it seems like
they learn this fact our friends on the
Left they learn this fact about Mike
Pence and his wife every few months they
learn it again
like they forget and then they learn and
every time this epiphany happens when
and it dawns on them again that oh my
gosh these people are Christian they're
offended and so the epiphany happened
once again this week when Mike Pence's
wife Karen got a job at a private
Christian school and this has elicited
many outraged headlines across the
mainstream media and many shocked and
appalled and frightened tweets and so on
now of course the stated reason for the
outrage is not that Karen pence a
Christian is working for Emanuel
Christian school a Christian school but
that it says it right there in the name
in case you were confused that's not the
reason that they're giving the reason
that they're giving is that the school
bands openly gay teachers and does not
admit openly gay students it also
prohibits all other manner of sexual
conduct that is considered immoral by
Christian teaching including premarital
sex teachers are required at this school
to affirm in writing the biblical
position on all of these moral issues so
let's let's just just take a we'll take
a look at some of these headlines here
so BBC News vice president's wife Karen
pens to teach at anti LGBT school New
York Times Karen pence is teaching at
Christian school that bars LGBT students
and teachers New York Post Mike Pence's
wife back teaching at school that bans
gay transgender students Karen pence
takes teaching job at Christian school
that bars LGBTQ students second lady
Karen pence faces backlash for teaching
at Christian school that bars LGBTQ
students the Washington Post Karen
Pence's job at a school that bans gay
employees is latest reminder of
administration's
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
here's what the Huffington Post has to
say about it Karen pence wife of Vice
President Mike Pence started it at a job
this week teaching at teaching art at
Emmanuel Christian school in Northern
Virginia it's not a school where
everyone is welcomed in a parent
agreement posted online the school says
it will refuse admission to students who
participate in or condone homosexual
activity the 2018 employment application
also makes candidates sign a pledge not
to engage in homosexual activity or
violate the unique roles of male and
female those are in quotes the
application says moral misconduct which
violates the bona fide occupational
qualifications for employees includes
but is not limited to such behaviors as
the following heterosexual activity
outside of marriage premarital sex
cohabitation extramarital sex homosexual
or lesbian sexual activity polygamy
transgender identity any other violation
of the unique roles of male and female
of male and females they also list
sexual harassment use or viewing of
pornographic material or websites the
application says that the school
believes marriage unites one man and one
woman and that a wife is commanded to
submit to her husband as the church
submits to Christ which of course is
just a quote from Ephesians 5 and that
it goes on from there parents are also
asked to sign an agreement saying that
they will cooperate with this policy of
biblical morality alright so here's the
thing about that there is no difference
between attacking Karen pence for
working at a Christian school and
attacking Karen pence for working at a
school that prohibits behavior contrary
to Christian teaching because any
legitimate Christian school will do
exactly that because that's what it
means to be a Christian that's why we
call it a Christian school as in there's
going to be Christian stuff going on
here this is a school for Christians by
Christians - Christians
and this is part of what it means to be
a Christian okay that's that's what it
means this is what every authentic and
credible Christian school ought to do
and does do so this is not by far not
the only Christian school that requires
a pledge of this sort they all should
and here's the thing the there are
plenty of Christian schools who do not
require these kinds of pledges and do
not have these these qualifications and
will hire teachers who are categorically
opposed to Christians teaching and will
and will admit students who have no
interest in Christian teaching
whatsoever but do you know what happens
with those schools they end up very
quickly not being Christian schools
anymore
what they end up being is just very
expensive secular private schools where
maybe there's a cross hanging on the
wall in the guidance counselor's office
or something that's what that's what
ends up happening so they lose their
identity as a Christian school obviously
when you start admitting people teachers
students when you when you when you
stock the the school up with with people
who have no interest in Christianity
it's not going to be a Christian school
anymore so that's why the Christian
schools that are interested in actually
remaining Christian schools that's why
they have these qualifications I think
the point is pretty clear here if if you
are manifestly and in principle opposed
to Christian morality then obviously you
don't belong at a Christian school there
are many other places you can go for
your education nobody is stopping you
from being educated but you shouldn't go
here why would you even want to go if
you are if you are that opposed to
Christian teaching on sexual morality
why would you want to teach at a
Christian school in the first place
you're you don't agree with them you
obviously think that Christianity is a
is a bigoted horrible thing why would
you want to be there they're doing you a
favor
by refusing you admission or employment
in the same way it would be it would be
terribly reasonable to exclude someone
from attending or or working for a
Muslim institution or a Jewish
institution if they if that person
rejects Muslim or Jewish teaching
prospectively although you're never
gonna see this when it comes to Muslims
they're there you know there are Muslim
members of Congress and there's there
aren't going to be a bunch of mainstream
media headlines saying that's so-and-so
Muslim Congress woman attends up an anti
LGBT mosque you're not gonna find
headlines like that even though every
mosque if it is actually a a Muslim
mosque that that teaches and and
promotes traditional Muslim teaching
they're all going to be anti LGBT in the
sense that Muslims also believe that
homosexual activity is sinful and that
marriage and that two men can't get
married that Muslims believe the same
thing but you're not ever gonna find
those headlines with with Muslims it's
only Christians because this is just
about it's not about you know standing
standing up against discrimination right
this is just about being anti-christian
that's what this is because again
Christian schools are in the business of
teaching Christianity
now they teach other things too but
through a Christian lens so if you're
not willing to impart or receive those
Christian teachings then there are many
other lovely educational options
available to you but it's really
important it's important here too to pay
attention to the backlash that Karen
pence is receiving here because the left
is revealing something and we should we
should we should take the revelation
seriously they're telling us something
about their agenda and we should listen
and take it seriously we talked about
this a few days ago with after the the
protests over a church sign there was a
church sign that a pastor put up saying
that you know standing for for Christian
moral teaching and they were protest
over that so we you know we made this
same point but to go over it again for
many years the Left claimed that they're
not interested in suppressing or outlaw
in Christianity they said that what they
claimed is that you know they just want
to live according to their own beliefs
without Christians shoving the Bible
down their throats or forcing them to
accept biblical principles just keep
your religion to yourself and and you'll
be fine is what they said well of course
I have a problem with the idea that
Christians should keep their religion to
themselves because that's not the
protection that the the First Amendment
the First Amendment does not have that
qualifier of well you have freedom of
religion as long as you keep it to
yourself
that's not what the First Amendment says
and also as a Christian I realize that
as a Christian I can't do that that
Jesus Christ commands us to go forth and
preach the gospel so they're so keeping
it to yourself is not an option
but in this case in the case of Karen
pence and her new employer they're doing
exactly what the left demanded the
school is merely trying to operate by
biblical principles within its own walls
on its own property okay it's a
Christian school that simply is trying
to be a Christian school it isn't
bothering anyone it isn't knocking down
anyone's door and and trying to control
what they're doing invading their home
lecturing them about their sexual Bator
it isn't doing that isn't preventing
anyone from working or living or or
enjoying their lives it's not preventing
anyone from doing anything it's just
saying very reasonably very
unobtrusively hey we're gonna conduct
ourselves bye-bye Christian moral
tradition if you don't want to accept
that moral tradition if you're opposed
to it fine by all means go somewhere
else we're just gonna be over here on
our little small corner of Northern
Virginia doing our thing that's all if
you don't agree with it than just you
don't have to come this is exactly the
approach that the left for years
endorsed and insisted upon for years
they said if you do that we won't bother
you because we are we're not anti
Christian we're not trying to control
you we just don't want you to control us
so this Christian school says all right
that's what we're gonna do and Karen
pence says hey I'm a Christian I want to
go teach art at a Christian school
that's all
suddenly though it's a problem suddenly
even Christianity behind closed doors on
private property in a private school is
a target for outrage and scorn
because it was a lie all along they were
never planning to stop just outside your
door just outside the walls of your home
or your church or your school that's
just what they said to lull you to sleep
before the next phase begins and it
looks like the next phase has begun what
does that phase entail well it's pretty
clear it entails attempts to change
transform morph deform or the word they
would probably use evolve Christianity
itself okay they want to change
Christianity itself they want to change
it doctrine
fundamentally this was always the plan
and if you adjust unfortunately so many
Christians were not paying attention but
if you had just paid attention to the to
the kinds of things they were saying
this would not come as a surprise to you
like when when when they go around
saying that everybody has the right to
not be discriminated against just that
idea alone now they they've been saying
that for years but if you just paid
attention to that and thought about it
for a minute okay so they're saying we
have some sort of universal right to
never be discriminated against so they
have that and then over here they say
while Christian teaching is
discriminatory so if that's
discriminatory and you have a right to
never be discriminated against well
combine those that's a problem for
churches for schools for any Christian
now of course in reality if we if we
were to if we're talking about actual
human rights if we're talking about the
rights that the Bill of Rights codifies
this idea that you have you have the
right to never be discriminated against
that just doesn't make any sense of that
of course is utter total complete
nonsense you know to discriminate simply
means to distinguish one from the other
to discriminate generally speaking
dictionary definition all that means is
to choose one thing instead of another
it's to prefer one thing over another
and so this
idea that you have a right that nobody
has ever allowed to distinguish you from
something else or to prefer someone else
over you or to choose someone else over
you this idea that no one ever has the
right to do that because you have the
right to be accepted everywhere in every
situation always all the time
that of course is crazy and if you try
to actually enact that into law you end
up with tyranny and you also end up with
with chaos but that's where this is
headed because what they're going to say
what they're saying now and what they
will continue to say even more
stridently is that is the next phase is
hey yeah you you know you basically have
the right to be Christian you you
basically have the right to go to church
and go to these schools and believe all
this stuff about Jesus but but I mean
nobody has the right to be a bigot even
if you're in your I mean just because
you're in a church that doesn't make the
bigotry any less bigoted you know well
your course you're not right to that so
all this stuff about homosexuals and
this stuff about you know the the the
the roles of women and men you well know
know that of course you can't well that
of course you're gonna have to toss out
I mean because that's just horrible
hurts people's feelings I mean you can't
do that so we'll just keep but you can
have everything else so we'll just get
rid of that though that that part we're
gonna do away with them but everything
else you can have still alright so I
posted some
yesterday a posted on on daily wire a
formal non apology because I went on Fox
yesterday morning Fox and Friends and I
made some comments about the mean the me
to movement and about that stupid
Gillette ad and the comments that I made
were picked up by a couple I'd Media
Matters and The Daily Beast and then as
you can imagine I got some will call it
critical feedback from some of their
readers and there are people emailing me
angry insisting that I should apologize
especially for the comments that I made
about about the me to movement and in
particular I said which I've said many
times on this show and in writing that I
didn't learn anything from the me to
movement because I already knew that
it's wrong to rape and harass people and
I didn't I didn't need anyone to tell me
that but that was very upsetting to some
people that opinion of mine was
upsetting and and I was told that I
should apologize so I wrote up a
statement explicitly not apologizing not
expressing any remorse and doubling down
on the original offending opinion now as
I said the reason I'm not apologizing is
is that while there are two reasons one
reason is that I'm right okay the
opinion that I expressed about the me to
movement is actually right so I'm right
about the YouTube movement and that's
why I'm not gonna apologize for saying
what I said about it that's one reason
that I'm not I'm not a part and in fact
as I said in the piece that I wrote if
anything I was in what I said on Fox I
was a little I was too I was too
generous to the me to movement because
they're all I said about me too in that
case I said is all I said is well didn't
I didn't learn anything from it but in
reality nobody learned anything from it
because everybody already knew that it's
wrong to treat women this way and yeah
some men still true still went ahead and
and entreated women that way but it's
not because they didn't know and I could
go even further than that and say that
not only was the Mito movement
ultimately useless but it was actually a
net negative it was harmful it was a bad
thing in the end it did a few good
things
gates smoked out guys like Weinstein and
so on but when you when you compare that
with all of the negative I think in the
end it's a net negative because of the
way the way that it it lumps all
different manner of of sexual
misbehavior into one big pile then makes
it impossible or difficult anyway to
distinguish one from the other and so
we're taking like actual rape and we're
lumping it in with inappropriate
comments and all of that so everything
is piled together and that is just a
very unhelpful and and it's just the
wrong way of dealing with these problems
things like sexual harassment rape abuse
these are things that need to be looked
at on a case by they need to be looked
at individually specifically on a
case-by-case basis when you start taking
all of them and just throwing them in a
pot together that's not helpful because
it doesn't help you get to the truth
into the reality of the situation
or the problem with the me2 movement is
that it was a it's a it's very
black-and-white oversimplifying thing
where the men are bad the women are good
it doesn't allow for discussions of
situations where women contributed to
creating inappropriate environments in
the workplace and it certainly doesn't
allow for conversations of about women
making false claims or exaggerated
claims or women engaging in consensual
sexual activity and then later on saying
that oh actually no I that was not
consensual doesn't allow for any
discussion about that and then we can go
on I'm not gonna I'm not gonna rehash
all of it because
actually it's irrelevant okay the second
reason why I'm not going to apologize
for that opinion or for any other
opinion that I give is that even if I
was wrong which I emphasize I'm not but
even if I was I haven't done anything to
anyone by expressing an opinion so yeah
I'm not wrong but let's put that to the
side for a minute because we've got this
idea that people should apologize for
opinions especially if they're later
convinced that they were wrong about the
opinion and then well in that case they
should go and apologize now if you
express a wrong opinion and you realize
that your opinion was wrong then it
makes sense to go back and admit that
you were wrong and say that you changed
your mind explain why you changed your
mind that's an honest and forthright
thing to do but apologize why to who
who exactly should receive the apology
that that's the problem with this with
this apologizing for an opinion thing
who are you apologizing to it's just an
opinion you you you believe that you
were right so you argued for your
opinion maybe later you realize that you
were wrong you didn't hurt anyone you
didn't cause any you didn't you didn't
affect anyone's life you just you just
expressed your point of view and your
point of view changed great so admit
that it did you who are you apologizing
to if I have a wrong opinion and you
have a right opinion and we argue and
you're saying that you're right and I'm
saying that I'm right and then later on
I decide okay you know what you were
right I now need to go and apologize to
you why what for traumatizing you with
my wrong opinion you were right why
would you be traumatized I mean you were
right the whole time see this is my this
is my prom
with public apologies in general really
any public apology because there's
always this question of who are you
apologizing to and why whatever you did
why does the whole world need to be
apologized to it was the whole world
really affected by whatever it was if
the world was affected then sure
apologized but but even if you really
did something terrible and wrong I mean
if I were to if I stole your car let's
say and and then I I had a change of
heart and I said you know what I'm gonna
bring your car back to you well yeah I
should apologize to you that I stole
your car and then hopefully you won't
call the police and we can just let
bygones be bygones at that point but
then do I also need to go and apologize
to my neighbor Jim and to Bob down the
street and to the cashier at the grocery
store no yes I did something wrong but
why would I apologize that I didn't
steal their cars they weren't affected
by it they don't care why are they owed
an apology they aren't the aggrieved
party I feel this way about when
politicians are caught having affairs
and then they get up and they give this
public apology in front of the world and
they're you know they're doing the press
conference and the the jilted wife is
standing there with them very awkwardly
and I always think why are you
apologizing to us we have apologize to
your wife apologize to your kids
apologize to anyone else you heard and
with affairs you hurt a lot of people
apologize to all of them on a personal
basis um but you didn't hurt me I'm not
hurt by this I mean I feel bad for your
life but you didn't hurt me I have to
apologize to me
think about how odd that is if someone
were to just stop you on the street and
say hey listen I'm really sorry
and you said well what do you solve
sorry for what you did I cheated on my
wife okay
you shouldn't
but what you don't apologize to her died
me I'm not the one that you need to
apologize I am NOT owed an apology in
that situation so the whole public
apology genre is absurd in my opinion
there may be the rare cases where it's
the right and proper thing to do as I
said cases where the public itself
really is harmed in some way then then
fine but for the most part the public
apology is just a kind of ritual that's
totally pointless but with opinions it's
even more pointless and so we really
need to get away from the idea that a
person might owe an apology for an
opinion even a wrong one a person might
be wrong about the opinion they
expressed that doesn't mean that they've
done something wrong by expressing the
opinion now if they know that they're
wrong about what they're saying and
they're saying in any way then they have
done something wrong because that's
hypocrisy but if they think that they're
right and it's a sincerely held belief
and they express it now the fact that
they think it that they're right doesn't
make it right but it does mean that they
haven't done the wrong thing by
expressing it they are just being
American citizens contributing to the
public dialogue which they have every
right to do I've changed my mind about
things plenty of things like for
instance I used to support the FairTax
which is a national sales tax to replace
the the income tax now I don't support
the Fair Tax anymore because I just want
to abolish the income tax entirely not
replace it with anything and then make
up for the loss in income to the
government by cutting government
spending by 40 percent that that now is
what I would support of course which
will never ever happen but anyway so
I've changed my view on that okay there
have been times in the past when I have
very passionately argued for the fair
tax now I've changed my opinion I've
realized I think that was the wrong
opinion but so I need a what apology who
do I apologize to who is owed an apology
because I was wrong about the fair tax I
don't think anyone is and whatever the
opinion was I does matter what the
opinion is nobody isn't owed an apology
so that's the main thing if you express
it
and this is really important because
people are becoming increasingly afraid
of expressing their views in any forum
whatsoever publicly because they're
terrified that well what if I'm wrong
and yeah there's a there's certainly a
hesitation a certain thoughtfulness that
you should have before you express a
view you should think about it you
should try not to express wrong opinions
but that's not really the fear that
people have it's it's that the fear is
well what if I'm wrong and then there's
the backlash and then you know I as if
like if I'm wrong about this opinion I
might it might hurt people or something
and then I've done some horrible
terrible thing by an expressing of you
that it turns out I was wrong about no
it's it's if you're wrong if express of
you and you're wrong then just it admit
you're wrong you don't owe anybody
apology didn't do anything to anybody
you didn't hurt anybody and this is part
of you know this is supposed to be part
of what it means to be in American what
it means to be just a thinking person is
sometimes you're kind of experimenting
with ideas and you're kind of working
through things and and so yeah maybe you
have an idea a point of view and you
think okay that's an interesting point
of view I want to express it I want to
let people know I want to talk about it
and then through the course of the
discussion maybe because of the
discussion you realize that okay no I
was wrong about that fine no big deal no
harm no foul was just a point of view
just an opinion
see sometimes it's through the
discussion it's through the the
interaction and the debate what that you
may discover that you were wrong about
the thing and you may not it unless you
express it and talk about it and put it
out there for sort of public examination
you may never discover the wrongness of
it so we have to ink
people to express their views and allow
people to be wrong without acting like
some sort of crime against humanity has
been committed finally I want to to end
with something I I figured there's been
a lot of negativity today and I wanted
to end with something oblivion and
powerful and this is really impactful
stuff Kamala Harris who is running for
president was interviewed by ABC and you
know ABC is always doing the really
hard-hitting interviews with politicians
especially Democrats and so here's the
tweet from ABC News here's here's their
headline
it says potential 2020 presidential
candidate Kamala Harris shares advice
for young women don't let anybody tell
you who you are you tell them who you
are
that is deep deep insight I mean I have
never heard it's a good thing that ABC
News made it into a headline because
I've never heard that kind of sediment
from anyone you know don't let anyone
tell you who you are I have you whoa
whoa have you ever heard that before
it's not like you've heard that from
literally every politician who's ever
existed on the face of the earth no
you've never heard I mean that's that's
and it's so much so profound it's so
moving I just I mean it kind of chokes
me up a little bit to be honest there's
some other great quotes from this ABC
interview I just want to share with you
some other Camille Harris quotes she
says if it's worth fighting for
then it's a fight worth having man let
me just start just stop and think about
that for a minute I mean
and my mind literally exploded in my
head right now it's like soup in my head
because I can't even if it's if it's
worth fighting for it so it's a fight
worth having
she also says my mother raised us with a
belief that we could do anything that's
just beautiful man that is so beautiful
she says there are going to be many
times that you are going to be the only
one like you in the room well I don't
you feel so inspired right now and then
she and this is this is this is the last
piece of advice and and again I mean for
ABC to be able to draw this out of her
so you find not only the brilliance of
Camille Harris but you find just whoever
did this interview I mean this is
someone who knows how to do a
penetrating just evocative kind of
interview so here's the last the last
piece of advice she says surround
yourself with really good friends oh man
sorry I mean I am getting a little bit
emotional I've just I've never
encountered wisdom like this and I
really feel like my whole life has been
changed now
I mean Camilla Harris
she makes Socrates look like a look like
a a vegetable in comparison so thank you
ABC and Thank You Camille Harris for
that I think it gives us
something too to think about and thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening god speak